وأريد إحضار
اللواء المتقاعد ميك رايان من الجيش الأسترالي
الذي ينضم إلينا من بريسبان أستراليا
شكرا جزيلا لوجودكم هنا معنا
مرة أخرى لذلك أريد أن أتحدث عن أه
مدينة غزة هنا المرحلة الأولى من الهجوم
هي عزل و  حاصروا المدينة إذن
ما سيأتي
بعد ذلك، مرحبًا كيم، لقد
حققت قوات الدفاع الإسرائيلية ذلك خلال الـ 24
ساعة الماضية عبرت الطريق إلى الساحل
وعزلت الجزء الشمالي
من غزة، وما سيأتي بعد ذلك هو
الضغط ببطء على حمص على الأرض  وفي
هذه الأنفاق مع السماح أيضًا
للمدنيين بالتدفق جنوبًا ومنع
أي تعزيزات من التدفق شمالًا إلى
مدينة غزة لصالح حماس، نعم أتساءل كيف
يفعلون ذلك، مما يسمح للمدنيين بالمغادرة
دون السماح لحماس
بالهروب، نعم إنها مشكلة صعبة جدًا
تخفيها حماس دائمًا بين
المدنيين  في غزة أه
وأعتقد أنه سيكون هناك معايير صارمة إلى حد ما عندما يقوم
الإسرائيليون بفحص الأشخاص المتجهين
جنوبًا ولكن في نهاية اليوم أعتقد أن هناك
ضرورة إنسانية للسماح
للناس بالذهاب جنوبًا في أسرع وقت
ممكن، نعم إلى متى  هل تعتقد
أن كل
هذا سيسير على ما يرام؟ لقد سار الأمر
بوتيرة سريعة إلى حد ما حتى الآن. أعني أن الإسرائيليين
تمكنوا من التقدم غربًا إلى
المحيط بسرعة كبيرة بالفعل على الرغم من أن ذلك
لم يكن عبر المناطق الحضرية، وأعتقد أننا
سنشهد تباطؤًا  في العمليات الآن،
يتحرك الإسرائيليون نحو قلب
مدينة غزة، حيث ستكون
المعركة الأصعب، حيث تمتلك حماس
معظم الأسلحة والمقاتلين
والقيادة والإمدادات، لذا يمكن أن
تتباطأ وتستغرق بضعة أسابيع، نعم
بعض أه أنا  أعتقد أن 30 ألف مبنى
قد تضررت بالفعل في شمال
غزة، بناءً على ما رأيناه
من معارك سابقة في أماكن مثل
الموصل والفوعة، هل يمكننا أن نرى أنك تعرف الكثير
أو أن معظم المدينة
دمرت بالكامل، أعتقد أننا سنذهب إلى  نرى
نسبة كبيرة منها مدمرة
للأسف والمباني المدمرة
تشكل مواقع دفاعية فعالة جدا
وحماس ستستخدمها أه
وكذلك شبكة الأنفاق الخاصة بهم للتنقل بين
مواقع القتال نستخدم الطائرات بدون طيار ستستخدم
iids وكل ما هو متاح لها
للإبطاء  الإسرائيليين وإيذائهم
قدر الإمكان
تطرقت إلى الضحايا المدنيين
مثل تلك الضحايا جبل أه كما
تحدثنا عن صبر
حلفاء إسرائيل سيتم اختباره بالفعل وقد رأينا
الرئيس بايدن يحذر إسرائيل من أن تلك
المعاناة المدنية  أه في غزة سوف يتسبب في
خسارة إسرائيل الدعم الشعبي للحرب، لقد
رأينا عددًا متزايدًا من
المشرعين الديمقراطيين يثيرون القلق
أيضًا، كيف تعتقد أن ذلك سيؤثر على
الجدول الزمني لإسرائيل وأهدافهم على المدى الطويل
هنا حسنًا، لا توجد ساعة لا نهائية
هنا  بالنسبة لإسرائيل يعرفون أنه في عام 2021
كان أمامهم 11 يومًا قبل أن يخبر الرئيس بايدن
أه نتنياهو أنه سينفد من
المدرج أنه قد يكون لديهم المزيد من الوقت هذه
المرة ولكن في نهاية اليوم
تدق الساعة على هذه العملية الدعم
ل  إسرائيل محدودة بين أقرب
مؤيديها، هناك عدد كبير جدًا من
الضحايا المدنيين الذي يمكن للناس أن يتحملوه في
هذه الأثناء رأينا الرئيس بايدن
يدعو إلى وقف مؤقت، ما هي
العواقب العسكرية أه لذلك، هل
تعتقد جيدًا أن الأمر سيعتمد على مكان
حدوث التوقف  يمكن أن يحدث ذلك في الجنوب فقط
ويستمر القتال في
الشمال. إذا حدث ذلك في الشمال فإن ذلك
سيخفف من ضغوط حماس
وهذا هو السبب في أن الجيش الإسرائيلي وحكومة
إسرائيل ليسا متأكدين من وقف إطلاق النار
في هذا الوقت.